all right this is the point in the show
every friday we talk about the things we
can't wait to see when
sunday or in this case technically
saturday rolls around shireen what do
you have first on your list this friday
well mike i'm looking forward to the
sooner bowl jalen hurts transferred from
alabama to oklahoma and color murray of
course transferred from my alma mater
texas a
m to oklahoma where he won the heisman
trophy and they're going to be going at
it
and i want to see can jalen hurts do
what he did in his first
start in a second start now that there's
a lot of film on him
now that they've seen arizona's gonna
find out mike
that he's not the statue that daniel
jones and colt mccoy were
last week and he's gonna move around and
he's gonna make them
try to keep him in the pocket uh good
luck with that
and he played great last week threw for
167
and ran for over a hundred and i just
thought he played an outstanding game in
his first start
and i'm eager to see what he's going to
do for the rest of year i think it's his
job the rest of the year
and if he does well the rest of the year
i think it's his job next year too
cardinals have experience in the
division with russell wilson also
at their own practices with kyler murray
and
whatever game plan they have here's
hoping it's better than what the saints
had because the saints weren't ready for
it they hadn't given up a 100 yard
rusher
in 55 games they gave up two in the same
game
one of whom was quarterback jalen hurts
and they also need kyler murray
to get it going again he's had four
straight games now under 50 yards
rushing after he had been so
dominant for most of the season to the
extent the shoulder injury
has been a factor it's got to be healed
or close to it by now it's been four
weeks so
that should be a great game with playoff
implications for both teams the thing
about
adding a seventh seed in the postseason
field for the afc and the nfc it creates
more games late in the season that are
relevant
to the postseason getting in clinching a
spot
ultimately getting a seed maybe a more
favorable seed than you otherwise would
get so
the eagle's very much alive and i keep
looking at week 17 as the potential
winner take all between washington
philadelphia for the nfc east
my first one can the browns avoid a
letdown
will they respond to their almost
close but no cigar game on monday night
against the ravens with the deflating
victory
will they respond the way that they
should not
in a woe is us and we we let one
loss become two that's one of sims big
talking points and i've seen that play
out for multiple teams this year
don't let one loss become two don't get
so caught up in what happened in one
game that you can't turn it around
and be what you need to be the next game
and
i think there's many reasons for brown's
players coaches and fans to feel very
good about what happened on monday
night but still short week six days
gotta turn it around and get back out
there
and they're gonna be playing a team that
is even more desperate than the browns
to get a victory the browns barring a
total collapse they're getting in
the giants they may be in the midst of
their collapse they need this one more
than the browns need it that's what
happened to the browns to a certain
extent on monday night
the ravens needed it more than the
browns this week the giants need it more
than the browns
can the browns recover from what
happened monday deliver the knockout
punch to the giants
punch their ticket to the playoffs and
get on the trajectory that we think they
should be on because of what we've seen
from them
the past two weeks even though they lost
monday night so shireen i i
i think they can i think they will but
we've seen
teams that have those heartbreaking
losses need another week
to turn it back around yeah i saw some
percentages a day from espn mike that if
the browns win their 95 percent
chance to get in the postseason and yes
of course they are first time since 2002
they would do that if they lose they're
still well above 50
i think it was 68 if they lose they're
gonna get in the playoffs but they want
to be rolling when they get in there and
i think we've seen a different
baker mayfield over the last three weeks
he has eight touchdowns one interception
he's only taken two sacks 312 yards per
game in that three game stretch
and i really do believe mike that they
are a better offense without odell
beckham and he is a better quarterback
without odell beckham because he can
spread the ball around
and not have to think about i've got to
target odell or he's going to get upset
there's none of that and on top of that
they can commit to the run they have two
the best one-two punch in the nfl at
running back
that allows them to run the ball let
baker pick and choose his spots
throw it to whoever's open and he's done
a great job of that he really has taken
a huge step kind of the step that we
thought he would take before now but i
think we're starting to see it now
he explained earlier this week that the
bye week gave them an opportunity to
take a step back
look at what they were doing wrong look
at what they were doing right improve
the passing game that way because they
didn't have the benefit of an off-season
program
or pre-season those reps that you would
use to get yourself ready
to go right out of the gates now
we've seen that since the bye week baker
mayfield has been
very good and they had won every game
they played up until monday night so
huge game for them all right shereen
what's next on your list of what you
can't wait to see
well mike i want to see if tom brady and
the bucks offense
can get rolling and they're pretty much
out of time right now
they've got to do it now they've got to
get into the playoffs and then be
rolling once they get in the
playoffs mike i have this lawnmower
right and it got some bad gas in it i
had let
gas sit there a little bit put the gas
in now it's bad gas so
sometimes it runs great and sometimes it
just decides it's not going to run that
day and
shuts off on me and just you have to
wait a while and then you pull it again
and eventually it'll start that's what
the bucks offense really reminds me of
they've kind of been
start and stop all year long and really
just haven't
been the offense i think we all expect
them to be with all those playmakers
they have on there and
one of the big differences is brady's
interceptions in the losses and there
are five losses he has eight touchdowns
and nine interceptions he's only thrown
11 interceptions this season
so it's those losses him turning the
ball over in those losses that's really
been a problem
but i would like to see him find some
connection with mike gavin's that just
hasn't
happened so far and this might be the
first time in
my kevin's career that he doesn't go
over a thousand yards
curious to see if yet again now with
ronald jones on the coveted list we will
see more leonard fournette so
the lashawn mccoy supplanting leonard
fournette is going to have a pin put in
it but
the antonio brown playing time how it
dropped from 75 percent to below 50
is that part of a strategic trend coming
out of
the buccaneers by and another thing i've
noticed all of a sudden bruce erin's
it's all sunshine and rainbows and
lollipops
between him and tom brady after all that
criticism and
some of it was overt some of it was
passive-aggressive and then this week
aryan says i don't know why everyone
criticizes
tom brady it's like dude you were
criticizing them all year long
and they they create an offense that
isn't suited to tom brady and then they
create the impression that the offense
is tom brady and anything that doesn't
go wrong is his fault so
yeah they need to get it rolling not
simply to keep winning now to get to the
postseason because they should they've
got the falcons lines and falcons to
finish it out if they don't
go 11 and 5 or 10 and 6 something's very
wrong
but they need to get to the point where
when the playoffs roll around
if they're the five seed and they go to
washington or new york or philadelphia
in the wild card round and then they
have to go to
green bay in the divisional round a team
they beat
38 to 10 this year and in a place where
it's going to be cold and i remember all
those years
where the tampa bay buccaneers have
never won a game when the mercury at
kickoff was below 40 degrees fahrenheit
well now you got tom brady the ultimate
cold weather quarterback
as your guy and you've got plenty of
guys who have come from other teams that
know how to play in the call they can be
very dangerous in the postseason bruce
arians has said it
that the home field advantage doesn't
matter this year doesn't matter if they
have to go on the road
and they they could they could get to
the nfc championship game
pretty quickly the question is could
they beat the saints or wherever else
they would be playing
but but uh this buccaneers team can
still be very dangerous even though they
had that stretch of three losses in four
games it got blown off the field by the
saints
speaking of the saints next one for me
can the saints outscore the chiefs it's
that simple
as we said earlier you're not going to
shut them down you're not going to shut
them out
you just have to outscore them and now
the drew brees is back michael thomas
out
taysom hill back in his quarterback of
all trades roll will they get
alvin kamara involved more in the
running game will they use him
extensively what will emmanuel sanders
do they need to find a way to score
points
it needs to be a shootout because you're
not going to hold the chiefs down
and if you build a lead you better hold
on to your hats because we know what
happens
when a team gets up by 10 or more points
against the chiefs that's when lightning
strikes
so that's what it comes down to the only
team that beat the chiefs this year
scored 40 points
that's what it's going to take it's
going to take more than 30
to beat the chiefs can the saints do it
shireen
yeah and mike they had two shut up two
shootouts not shutouts shootouts earlier
this year and they lost both and they
were in back-to-back games they gave up
34 to the raiders in 37 to the packers
and they lost 34 24 and 37 30. so
it is going to take getting i agree with
you that 40 point
milestone for them to win this game and
that's what they weren't able to do
and those two losses they had early and
one of those two losses or both of those
losses are going to come back to bite
them probably
with the packers likely to get home
field advantage throughout the
postseason and get that first week by
that the saints aren't going to get and
if they had just beaten the raiders way
back then
they'd have a better chance of doing
that now so they do have to score a lot
of points this is a crucial game for
them
and trying to win uh stay in that race
for that home field advantage if they're
gonna do that if they lose this one as
you said mike it's over the packers are
gonna get that spot
what do you have next on your list of
things you can't wait to see
well i want to know mike if the steelers
can
right the ship they look like the
titanic right now they're really taking
on some water can they plug up those
holes and and get the ship back
on the track started out of course 11-0
and now they've lost their two games and
they averaged in the first 10 games
almost 30 points a game and now in the
last three games they've
averaged 17 points they're just not the
same team
ben roethlisberger the last four games
has had a passer rating below 90. it
doesn't help that his receivers are
dropping passes left and right they
can't run the ball
um they're last in the league in 31st in
rushing
the last team mike to get to a super
bowl to have a rushing
offense that bad was the colts in 2009
they were actually 32nd in the league
in rushing offense when they got there
and of course they didn't win that super
bowl they lost the saints so
they've got to find a rushing game
they've got to find their receivers
catching the ball they've got to get ben
throwing the ball down the field which
they haven't been able to do
see if they can get that offense
clicking again we know their defense is
good it's all going to come down
to big ben and how that offense can play
as to how far the steelers can go this
season
we had ed bouchette with us last week
talking about the steelers and their
struggles in the running game
and he said that he had spoken to jerome
bettis i went back and read the article
where bouchette gets some some feedback
and some input from betis about the
running game and he made a great point
you commit to the running game not
out of the blue you commit to the
running game in training camp you decide
that this is what we are built upon this
is who we
are and they never made the full
commitment to the running game they have
badly gotten away from it whether it's
ben roethlisberger audibling to passes
or they're doing a lot of rpo concepts
and he's choosing to throw when he could
hand it off
they're not mauling guys the line of
scrimmage
james connor when he came back last week
had 18 carries on
or 18 yards excuse me on 10 carries
that's not gonna get it done
and uh they can't just keep throwing
these four and five yard passes
getting their receivers blown up that's
one of the reasons why they're dropping
the football they're getting hit as soon
as they catch the
pass because the defensive backs know
what what the game is so
they've they've got to get this right
and what better chance to do it than on
monday night football against the
bengals but boy if the
browns wins sunday night and the bengals
somehow
upend the steelers and you know when a
team's losing games
i want to see them win before i will
conclude they've
fixed their problems if the bengals
would win that game
makes for an interesting final two weeks
because the steelers have the colts
and then the steelers have the browns
there's still a chance week 17 is going
to come down to
steelers at browns in cleveland for the
division title
not as big of a chance because the
browns lost monday night but still a
chance that the steelers can't get it
turned around
next one for me the vikings and the
bears are facing
off in as a practical matter and
elimination game although i don't think
the winner is going to make it to the
playoffs either the loser is done
and with mitchell trubisky back uh he's
matched up well against the vikings he's
played well against the vikings even
though he's also gotten injured twice
against the vikings
there was a game two years ago week 18
or week 17 excuse me
and the vikings just needed to win to
get into the playoffs and the bears
weren't playing for anything and
trubisky and the bears beat the vikings
and
and i think if trubisky was playing when
the bears and the vikings played on
monday night earlier this year trubisky
would have won the game because the
bears would have converted some early
opportunities into points made the
vikings desperate
and their offense would have crumbled
trubisky can beat the vikings
trubisky can play well enough to help
the bears
pull the inside straight to get to the
playoffs this year when you look at the
cardinals
schedule down the stretch you look at
the bears schedule down the stretch it
is not an impossibility
and it starts with the bears winning on
sunday can trubisky do it
what will the bears think of trubisky if
he does what will other teams think of
trubisky if he does he's going to be a
free agent after the season
and it's becoming pretty clear i don't
know that it was a mistake at the time
to go with nick foles but
over the passage of weeks they probably
would have been better off sticking with
trubisky and now trubisky may be the guy
who saves them shireen
yeah no question mike and they're gonna
get to find out what they have in him
and if they didn't already
know but he's playing it at a better
level and i found his quotes from this
week pretty interesting mike he said
that
they're doing things offensively that i
want to do
so were they not doing that before this
week i don't
know but in the past three games they've
averaged over 30 points a game
and he's really played well so maybe he
is taking that next step maybe it took
sitting behind nick foles for a while
for him to figure out
what was going on and for maybe the
offensive
geniuses on that side of the ball to
figure out what he liked i don't know
but they do look like a different
offense over the last three weeks
all right time for one more each quickly
what's your next one
i got will t.y hilton light up the texas
again you know his nickname is the mayor
of houston and it's for a reason he's
just
absolutely dominated the texans they
played two weeks ago
eight catches 110 yards and a touchdown
it was his first i didn't realize this
his first hundred yard game in two years
2018 was the last time he had one of
course he was pretty banged up
a lot last year but in the last three
weeks 17 catches 277 yards and four
touchdowns t
y hilton suddenly is looking like t y
hilton again
yeah uh for me how many yards will derek
henry get because he got 15
32 on the year he's got a shot at 2 000
and a very very outside shot at 2105
which is the all-time single season
record adrian peterson made a late
season assault on eric dickerson's
record back in 2012 and
look there aren't many guys in the nfl
that have a shot at averaging 191 to get
to 2105.
it's like 156 i believe to get to 2
000. how many yards does he get against
the lions
and then that will really set the stage
for what kind of performance we need to
see from him week
16 and week 17 but he's got a chance
he's got a chance and
look i i love to witness history we all
do and we both really like derek henry
he's been on the show this year
he's a great representative of the
titans he's a modern-day jim brown and
shireen i
i i'm hoping he gets at least 175
so he has an outside chance at 2 000 at
a minimum
2105 maybe if everything falls just
right
another thing on my list i love to see
mike i love to see him run every week
it's it's great and it and he is a
throwback player and it's just fun to
see and i hope he does get there
and make it exciting those last two
weeks to see just how many yards he can
churn up and see if he can get close to
that record or break that record
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports